Hôm nay, thống thống miếng đô năng tròm ngày 1 bốn thống người cho biết,
Isoran đã đồng ý đường dút quần bà đầu tại giải ngaza.
Đồng thái mọi đường cho lệnh bà nếu lúc lợi hàng mắt sụng xanh nhận.
Ông tròm tiên bố, một khi phong trò hủ giáo này đồng ý,
lệnh hôm bàng sẽ hiệu lực ngay lập tất,
và hỏa đậu cho đổi tuần nhăn còn tín sẽ chính thức bắt đầu.
Ông tròm cũng nhận mạnh sẽ không tức giải thêm bất kỳ sự chí hoạch nào nữa,
trong đến chuyện hoa bình.
Về phy yên, thủ đồng vét cho mình nên tài cho hủ xanh nhận đã cửa đoàn bàng xanh,
a cập để hoàn tất cả chỉ tiếp kiện thoát,
với mục tiêu dời hạn đến chuyện trong văn ngày,
ông bày tò hi vọng các con tín Isoran sẽ được chờ về nhà,
trong lệ giỏi thái xú cót, mùm sau thống người sắp tới ý,
đồng thời khẳng định sẽ giải giá hà mắt bằng biệt phá hỏa rao,
theo kéo hãi cũng trăm, nhưng điều không biệt pháu quần sự sẽ được tải áp đặt.
Về phy yên a chục rao hòa giải ác gặp,
bộng ai giáo nước này thông báo sẽ lòng các phá đoàn Isoran và Hamas,
trong những sau thống mười để bàn xí tiếp hơn về thảo thần sau lỗi còn tín dựa trên điều kiện thực liệu.
Cung ai có thể ủng tròm, nhà đồ tư, bất đồng sản tại chúng đồng gia REST CUSNER và đặc phải viên nhà chàng Steve QuickCorp,
cung đã lên đường với Cairo để phối hợp tìa.
Có thể nói, các hòa đồng ngoài giáo đang được cấp bên súc tiến,
tuy nhiên trên thực liệu, bảo lực bất chứa dừng lại.
Yến mắm mấy sống người là thiết mạng trong các phụ khục cích mới tại thành phố gaza.
Ngày mừng mưa thăm người trong đỏ của cac sẽ em.
Nâng tổng súng người thiết mạng trong cuộc súng đột kéo dài đã hai năm qua tại giải gaza.
Lên hơn sống mới bài nghiên người.